let me tell you about a little spell
called teleport for many years it lay
unchanged in league of legends and then
recently riot reworked it in a major way
now people are scrambling to figure out
if everything is still okay or if this
might have a massive domino effect on
how pretty much the entire game is
played and some people are not happy
about that let me show you why
[Music]
all right before we get into the video
make sure you are subscribed to the
score esports if you don't want to miss
videos just like this one we are going
to be doing more weekly don't at me
league videos just like this so that's
your thing make sure you subscribe and
leave a like if you enjoyed it alright
first off i just want to say that i got
a few comments on the chem tech video i
did before christmas where people were
like whoa relax all right relax there's
plenty of time left in pre-season for
riot to fix things i'm sure they're
going to make things better well happy
new year they did cool so yeah riot had
over a month to make significant changes
to chemtech they said they were open to
big changes but apparently chemtech is
working as intended
we'll have to see how it all pans out in
pro play but look as [ __ ] as
chemtech seems to be at least teams have
seen this coming from quite a way off
but there's one change that they'll
certainly not have time to play around
with or scrim other teams with the new
teleport changes now i know changes to a
summoner spell might not sound quite as
sexy as a chemtech dragon [ __ ] up the
entire game but bear with me basically
the new teleport can only be used on
allied towers and not minions wards or
ally objects like teemo shrooms or
jarvan's lance it also has a cooldown of
360 seconds at all levels as opposed to
the cooldown decreasing with levels like
before then when tower plating falls at
14 minutes your teleport becomes
unleashed teleport which is basically
the same as the old teleport you can
teleport to all the stuff that you used
to be able to except it has a flat cool
down of 240 seconds at all levels so
basically for most of the early game
you've got a walmart version of teleport
which means you can only teleport to
towers now we've known about these
changes for over a month now but since
they went live on friday
old habits have been dying hard
hello
what are they tp
what is going on
oh this change dude
now if you're the kind of person that
dips into league once every month or so
then first of all well done seriously
but you may be wondering how will this
affect the game and why have riot made
these changes well in the early game
there'll be no more stacking a wave by
teleporting to your last minion you
won't be able to stabilize the lane so
easily if you get killed early and
perhaps the most important change for
bot laners you won't be able to flank
them at level six with a well-timed
teleport and that's huge honestly for as
long as i play the game the early bot
lane teleport flank has been a staple of
the game as a jungler i'd often find
myself pathing bot just to try and
counter the enemy psion that is about to
run over my bot lane because they didn't
clear a teleport ward behind them i
found a top or mid laner turning up to
these fights and then converting it into
an early dragon to be interesting it was
usually the first bit of team play you
actually got to experience before the
mid game so personally my initial
reaction when the news first dropped was
ah [ __ ] they're gonna remove a bit of
excitement from the early game it was
mad at times it was messy but it was fun
but i'm not an 80 carrier main early
teleport flanks have been the bane of
their existence for years at this point
and these changes may actually finally
give them some breathing room
the tp changes huge for me playing bot
lane by the way
huge
because i get [ __ ] tp'd on all game
people are [ __ ] is t1 fighting this
to you and fighting
dude it was like tptp and then my laner
is a [ __ ]
enemy later the tp and i'm going to tp
20 seconds later then they fail tp
they still can't tp flank by the way
oh my god this is actually bliss
i think i'm creaming my pants
double left raises a good point on his
stream which is that players have just
got too good at utilizing teleport to
the point where it's become more than
just a good way to get back to your lane
a good teleport to bot lane can pretty
much win or lose you the entire game at
least that's what it feels like in pro
play this concept has become so
important that it's reached pretty
absurd levels in recent years does
anyone remember this absolute fiesta
from last year wade's coming in he'll be
the first to arrive does have a level
advantage barrel's to be jumped on
february showing up
from everybody baby waves running away
here with about 200 hp khan shows up
show makers ready to go now as well
everybody's joined the bottom lane party
one of the criticisms of this change is
that it makes the game more flat more
predictable that it removes a pretty big
dimension of the early game but that's
something that doublelift straight up
disagrees with it becomes the most
one-dimensional summoner spell on the
game seems odd not really no
the the thing about tp now is like you
can still use it in ways that
in some ways that you were gonna be able
to before like for example
pre-14 minutes you can use it to get
drag or herald
pre-14 minutes you can use to defend
your teammates on a dive you cannot use
it offensively to set up a dive but you
can use it defensively to defend one
there's still a lot of ways to use tp to
your team's advantage i think people
will get creative look it's obvious
something has been lost from the game
here things aren't going to be the same
anymore but even if we have lost one
dimension doesn't mean these changes
won't create whole new ones what will
the bot lane look like now that 80
carries don't have to worry about being
slapped by an irelia at the 10 minute
mark will they play more aggressively as
a viewer it could be interesting to see
a bot lane that's more of a true 2v2
where people aren't playing scared and
are more willing to take trades but even
if you can't push an enemy bot lane
under their turret more easily you won't
be able to dive them as well as before
because a your teleporting ally won't
have a minion to teleport to before 14
minutes and b
their teleporting ally can just tp to
the turret and defend and see that is
interesting i have no idea what that
could mean for the bot lane meta and
don't forget about how this might shape
top lane with teleport being a weaker
summoner spell it might open the door
for more ignite or ghost picks and these
combat summoners could make top lane a
more bloody place to be safer laners who
relied on teleporting back to a stacked
way for a free back
could find life a lot more difficult
these days compared to their ghost or
ignite opponents that doesn't mean the
teleport is completely [ __ ] though we
have to remember it's still the same
summoner as it was after the 14 minute
mark the lpl started yesterday and every
top laner that day still chose teleport
in all five of the games that were
played it's not like it's suddenly trash
and we still saw a party in the bot lane
with a flank tp it just happened after
the 14 minute mark like right after
another scout of the week hits could
just be first oh nice cataclysm flash
away from melbourne x back up but for
cool down so mega death rocket almost
does the job but there's a package into
the middle gory doesn't connect it
though really as the flight comes
through the box down as well but fbx or
winning the fight that's the tp
advantage at work two members already
dead way under tariq sonic wave with a
huge kick not even needed perhaps teams
are still learning how to play without
teleport and the changes in pro play
won't happen until further down the line
i kind of like the fact that essentially
one tiny change stopping players from
teleporting to minions or wards before
14 minutes might have this insane ripple
effect that decides champion and
playstyle matters for the foreseeable
future
it's cool i think there's a natural bias
to say that these kinds of changes make
the game less dimensional but that might
be because we haven't had a chance to
see yet what kind of unforeseeable
dimension this change might bring about
i've no doubt that some pro players will
have messed around with these changes on
the public test server but i doubt that
many pro teams will have had a chance to
scream with it yet so as pro games start
up again the question is
will the meta have shifted because of
these teleport changes and if so who's
going to figure it out first this is
normally the point in the video where i
talk about what else there is in the
patch but honestly there's not that much
it's kind of mad we've got four champion
tweaks a couple of system changes and
some new items that don't seem to have
pissed off too many people yet but the
teleport changes really are the main
headline here and obviously chemtech but
we're done talking about that for now
happy season 12 to you all good luck
with the grind go and unleash some
teleports and let me know if these
changes have made the game a thousand
times worse a thousand times better
or maybe just somewhere in between
make sure you've subscribed to the
channel if you want to miss if you want
to miss videos like this it really
really helps us out yeah
and if you are enjoying this video make
sure you leave a like
leave a like it helps us out we really
appreciate it bless
you i'm not saying bless you actually
i've never said i've never actually
blessed all my life that's mad what am i
doing